merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous débattons du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative depuis le 2 mars dernier
dans cette émission votre avant ont
commencé les jours précédents en
commission de très nombreuses
amendements ont été déposés examinés et
les débats ont été nourris
nous avons eu ensemble dans cette
émission 74 heures de débat sur un sujet
central celui de l'avenir de système de
retraite par répartition à chaque
article malgré des discussions de fond
malgré des avancées portées par la
commission bien sûr par plusieurs
groupes nous le regrettons mais
l'obstruction est devenue un choix
méthodique et répété des groupes
d'opposition nous avons eu quelques
illustrations pas plus tard que ce matin
je pense à la déclaration de madame la
sénatrice brûlant qui nous dit très
clairement et je la remercie de cette
clarté qu'à chaque fois que nous avons
nous avancerons tous sera mis en oeuvre
pour nous ralentir je pense aux
expressions utilisées hier au sujet du
dépôt des sous amendements qui ont été
présentés comme une vie sans fin et avec
la volonté de faire en sorte que le
nombre de sous-amand déposés soit
toujours plus important pour empêcher le
Sénat de se prononcer dans la clarté sur
l'ensemble du texte et sur les
dispositions de fonds je pense aux
séries d'amendements identiques ou
analogue avec des déclinaisons de
profession avec des déclinaisons
d'institutions à concerter avec des
déclinaisons de dates lorsque les sous
amendements non comme seul objet que de
décaler d'un jour puis de deux jours
puis de 3 jours puis de 4 jours la date
de remise d'un rapport lui-même demandé
par un parlementaire d'un groupe
d'opposition cela caractérise une
obstruction méthodique et une volonté de
priver le Sénat de sa capacité à
délibérer et à se prononcer dans la
clarté pour dire qui soutient et qui ne
soutient pas les dispositions qui sont
proposées le choix du gouvernement la
ligne du gouvernement la seule qui
vaille à nos yeux
et celui de la clarté des débats pour
les sénateurs comme pour les Français
qui nous regardent et qui vous regardent
nous faisons un choix clair nous avons
une volonté claire celui d'éviter de
contourner et de mettre fin à une
obstruction qui est devenue systématique
et qui n'a comme ça l'objectif je le
répète d'empêcher les sénateurs et les
sénatrices de se prononcer sur des
dispositions de ce texte et sur cette
réforme qui est majeure pour l'avenir
des Français
nous aurions pu considérer que le
calendrier parlementaire tel que prévu
par la Constitution la loi organique
serait suffisant nous considérons qu'il
est absolument essentiel que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur le fond dans la
clarté que cette clarté des positions
toute respectueuse dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité dans le soutien
comme à l'opposition à ce texte mais que
cette clarté des débats est tout à fait
primordiale pour pouvoir ainsi avancer
et que cette réforme puisse continuer à
être discutée
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente en application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas en cause ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences
le gouvernement propose que soit soumis
à sevate unique les amendements pardon
pour les itérations numéro 21 33 21 34
21 41 21 36 modifié par le
sous-amendement 471 21 35 21 37 21 39 21
43 21
44 21 46 21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 à
l'article 9
pour ce qui concerne l'article l'article
10 les amendements 21 54 20 59 rectifier
terre 21 55 20 58 rectifié 20 60
rectifié bis 21 56 21 57 21 58 21 59 et
21 60 pour ce qui concerne les
amendements portant additionnels après
l'article 10 les amendements 22,95 20 24
20 21 61 rectifié bis 45 47
475 re